is no time
[Music]
the time is 13. o'clock
[Music]
hey everybody here we are please tell me
if the audio is okay because we were
[ __ ] around with the microphone
earlier the image looks a lot better on
your thing and i'm not it's totally the
same i don't know what you're talking
about that's probably because you don't
have glasses yeah
so you can't see it it's like so yeah
tell me if the audio is okay because we
actually we put the um the microphone
arm in so the microphone would be there
so i'm you know because tom like pushed
it and like he turned it off but i
turned it back on but i don't know if he
[ __ ] with any of the other controls so
hopefully it's all okay and also tell me
it seems like the stream is gonna go
better what i did yeah sabrina says
sounds good looks good
um
what i actually did after we talked to
you guys on wednesday night and we had
all those problems with you know the
buffering and whatnot because of the
satellite i went ahead and uh upped my
phone
plan to unlimited with a 15 uh gig
hotspot
add-on
and so i'm actually streaming through
my phone service
and so far
it seems to be working much better my
little [ __ ] on obs i don't know if you
guys use obs or anything but there's
like a little square
and if your stream is going good it'll
stay green and it stayed green like this
whole time so
when we were streaming on wednesday
night it kept going like red yellow
green red yellow green red yellow green
so we'll we'll see hopefully
hopefully this is like gonna be okay i
downgraded the [ __ ] any just in case but
hopefully it's gonna be okay but yeah i
turned on mobile tethering usb tethering
and uh we're gonna roll with that for
the time being
and uh hopefully not have to stream with
this [ __ ] satellite anymore because
that was uh pretty lame yeah too slow it
was too slow yeah so you know but
hopefully this will be better like i
said i didn't want to have to like buy a
mobile hotspot and my phone was enabled
i just had to
pay twice as much per month uh as i was
paying
to you know get unlimited data so i
could stream so you know and uh it
actually has improved a lot of things
i'm on using it and that's what that's
how it's coming in on using it yeah well
[Laughter]
well you know it looks like [ __ ]
ah yeah well uh honestly i i appreciate
everyone talking about like uh you know
the mobile hotspot stuff because i
looked into that and i was just kind of
like oh well i don't why don't i just
use my [ __ ] phone you know
all right
hello tila hey beautiful people happy
friday i'm going to be in and out of the
chat work calls
okay well
we're glad to see you guys anyway it's
friday night
i'm so
oh
what a day well not not today yesterday
you guys yesterday
was a nightmare day
for both of us for different reasons
um
there's i mean if you guys want to hear
about it it's just kind of like oh my
god we remember we were making the
shirts for absolution fest which is
going on right now actually
it started last night
and uh i got most of the we got most of
the shirts done thank you tb triggers
here's a lucky super chat in hopes the
stream goes well i know i'm hoping too
this is the first time i've been
streaming through my phone as a mobile
hotspot um i've been using it all day
like to do other things like upload
videos and download things and stuff
like that and seems to be working good
so and like i said i've seen all i've
seen is a little green light and it
seems like it's going good so hopefully
it'll
hang in there hang in there little phone
you can do it but yeah so
we had done most of the shirts we screen
printed them and we dropped them off
uh you know with somebody that drove
them over to tampa
but unfortunately we had a bunch of
blank tank tops and a bunch of blank uh
extra extra larges that were held up
um so they didn't actually get here
until yesterday at four o'clock
and they needed them in tampa
by 6 30 p.m today
so
ups brings them tom wasn't here because
he was back at the old house like fixing
[ __ ] and everything and i was just like
holy crap so i just like pull all the
shirts in and i just like screen printed
them like really really fast and it's
well as fast as you can do because if
you do screen printing it it's not
really that fast it like takes a while
she had them we had like i had to dry
all of them and everything and then i
said okay i'll overnight them it'll be
fine i'll go to fedex but then by the
time they were done
uh it was getting to the point where tom
wasn't back yet i didn't have my car
fedex was gonna close
and then i got to a point where they're
just like okay well it's too late now
you can't overnight it so i was like
[ __ ] now i'm gonna have to drive to
tampa and drop them off on friday but
thankfully thankfully
uh someone
uh mouse the dj
she uh had a friend that kind of lived
around here that was going over to tampa
today and she came by here
bless
bless her [ __ ] heart she came by here
early this morning and picked the shirts
up and is taking them to tampa before i
was like
sweetie it's just like give me all your
information i will send you money it's
just kind of like you saved my ass i was
just freaking out yesterday freaking out
doing all those shirts yeah you know
jenny was gonna have to drive down there
i was gonna have to drive all the way to
tampa by myself in my shitty ass car
sorry to take those shirts and i was
just kind of like oh my god i sent a
message to mouse and said come on mouse
with the friends list like yours you
can't get somebody that's in lives
around here that is going to tampa
because a lot of people are going it's a
big it's a big three-day godfather and
she's a hold on a couple hours later yay
got it i got it you know she said she
could come at any time i said all right
yeah she came at like quarter past eight
this morning yeah and picked up stuff
and she's like i was just like oh my god
you were a [ __ ] lifesaver i thought i
was gonna have to drive all the way to
tampa today and i really didn't want to
yeah especially not by myself because
she went got mail
it did
so so between that because
i was stressing out about that and then
i was stressing out about uh you know
the satellite connection and i was like
because it wasn't just the stream i was
having problems with i was having
trouble like uploading videos that's why
if you're a patron you know normally you
would get earl like a day early access
that's why you didn't get early access
to the elephant man video because i
couldn't get it to upload like i tried
it like three and it was taking like
four or five hours and then like it
would crash and then i have to start
over and it was just kind of like this
huge nightmare and i was just kind of
yesterday i mean tom came back from the
house and i was just like please shoot
me i was just like oh my god this has
been like the worst yeah we're going to
the festival tomorrow yeah we're going
tomorrow that's when star knight's plan
yeah it's been it's been three days yeah
and and yesterday it's you know like i
said i can't afford to go three days
jesus christ i mean chlorine was playing
though
i thought they were playing uh i thought
they were playing tomorrow night are
they i didn't see that on the lineup
i have to look i made i made the flyers
but there's so many i'm gonna plug
chlorine you guys need you guys need to
see there's so many bands that i forgot
which ones were playing which
k-o-r-i-n-n-e
yeah corey
it's uh it's really good bad it sounds
like something from the 80s yeah it's
like it's just two guys right i think
yeah two really young god guys
it's a ton of bands are playing there's
a [ __ ] ton of them i think they're from
chicago aren't they i can't really talk
to him it was one of the first they
played a couple of years ago yeah
a couple years ago and i bought a shirt
and there was there was this song i
didn't know who did it i kept hearing it
played on like some of the vaporwave
channels
and it came on and i was like it's them
that's them and our [ __ ] yeah we were
at the festival we're like hey we know
that song i know that song where'd you
hear that and that's the dude they're
playing new retro
wave
okay yeah
and uh
what was it what was in that song
something under the heaven oh yeah i
can't remember now yeah it's a real good
real good song yeah yeah i still i have
that shirt too it's cool it's got like
silver angel wings something another
heaven
but yeah it's a [ __ ] ton of bands and
you know they're gonna have
uh you know they have like a bunch of um
what do you call it like vendors and
stuff like that it's a bit and it's big
it's that it's at actually two different
locations i think it's like crowbar
uh and where's that's the orpheum or no
not the orpheum what's the place called
in ebor city yeah tampa well let me plug
mouse's channel too she's on obscura
undead on uh youtube yeah she does a
little uh she does some other stuff too
what else does she did she have a couple
other channels
we did a shirt for her that wasn't
obscura comedian after communion after
dark
yeah that's kind of the right their
internet radiation that's our internet
right over there but yeah so yeah we did
communion after dark shirts and we did
the absolution shirts
and like i said it was
we got most of them done and delivered
but then i was just kind of like
the tank tops and the
two xl's for whatever reason were
delayed
and i didn't get them until like late
yesterday and i had to screen print them
all by myself and then you know it was
too late to overnight them so thanks jim
thanks david uh thank you david june
hope the stream goes well me too yeah
you guys have never mentioned a band i
haven't liked corey is awesome
yeah they're so good and they're super
nice guys yeah they're real nice yeah
it's like we went and uh we talked to
them like at the last i guess the last
absolution was not last year was the
year before and cory were at that one
too and we went up and talked to them
afterward like at their merch table
and we were like yeah we heard you on
new retro wave and stuff and they were
going to buy some of their music but
they said all we have is vinyl and i'm
like oh my god
yeah but um i was like i don't even have
a record player but i was like well give
me a shirt then and they were just like
so
um they were so like appreciative
they're like oh my god she got the last
black shirt everything else was white
and that and i was like man i can't wear
that to a glove
and they're like well i can't wear white
because it makes me look like six feet
wide yeah
all the uh all the only thing only white
was left
all the black stuff sold out
yeah well obviously it's a goth festival
all the black stuff is gonna you know
don't even bother like putting stuff on
white ain't no [ __ ] gonna wear that
[Laughter]
i know it's like easier to print and
everything but it's like nobody's gonna
wear it nobody's gonna wear weight
uh do you all have any stickers or
decals
you know what we don't
maybe we ought to
uh dj maniac says i'm not hanging around
long it's goth night
oh okay zach
thank you zach
go ahead and read it happy you got the
shirt thing worked out guys yeah me too
seriously yesterday i was ready to
[ __ ] kill myself because i was just
so yeah
we're both [ __ ] just on the edge
we're
[ __ ] tired of [ __ ]
it's gonna be a miracle that this is
gonna if this is a great show although i
feel sometimes honestly i think this
yeah i think this might be a great show
because i have a lot of opinions about
uh elliot roger and about the incel
movement in general and uh movement is
it yeah well i'll call it a movement
it's a it's a all community let's call
it a community yeah um
this [ __ ] goes way back man that was
back in the back in the [ __ ] 90s
internet i remember those guys
well that's the
threat that's where that [ __ ] started
well the thing about it was that and
we'll get into that in a minute but the
whole incel community that wasn't
started as how it turned out you know
what i mean it was a totally different
it was just started dudes talking to
each other in in in from what way i
remembered it from my point of view it
was dudes talking to each other on um
discussion boards and then guys were
complaining and then they post a picture
of themselves everybody start laughing
well of course you got problems man
flick it and then if you find out that
all these dudes making these grandiose
pose posts in these threads
are [ __ ]
overweight basement dwellers [ __ ]
hoarder types
that are [ __ ] they're they're a lot
of them were hilarious some of the [ __ ]
that they did was just [ __ ] legendary
but no not the kind of guy can i say
though that the term incel was
originally coined
by in the in 93 93 94 by a bisexual
woman
and uh she
she had it the community that was just
like for everybody to just talk about
you know just kind of like commiserate
about how they wanted to have a sexual
relationship but they couldn't and um
you know so she just started it as that
and it wasn't anything to do with you
know just men or anything like that
woman started it um and then after a
while she you know she had that for a
while but then she was like well she you
know got busy and she couldn't really
maintain it anymore and then ended up
selling the forum to some stranger that
she didn't know and then after that it
ended up taking on this whole other
connotation and she disavowed it later
on because she's like yeah i'm
i didn't mean for that like uh word to
become that she's like uh you know that
wasn't anything like that sales too
i know they do but there's there's
actually a segment of the incel
community that believe that women cannot
be in cells that it's impossible no not
true because they think that women can
get sex any time they want and i'm like
not true no that is absolutely not true
not true especially beyond a certain
age well you never did finish wednesday
i know well because you started talking
uh yeah again thank you zach uh happy
you got the shirt thing worked out like
i said me too uh also see no time to die
oh my god it was good and not just
because i haven't been in a theater
since last january lol uh tila said yeah
i enjoyed no time to die as well good
movie i'm sure we are going to go well
we have man we have to go see that we
have to go see the venom movie yeah uh
whenever that new when's that when's
that uh new horror movie start that last
night in soho or whatever i really want
to see that that looked weird as [ __ ]
and i'm into it the um
yeah i mean my understanding is is you
know that the no time to die
i know what happens at the end i've
heard um man you spoiled it already
don't tell me don't tell me why i can
tell what it is just by them saying
don't tell them about the end and okay i
know what they're talking about
um
to me it's obvious when [ __ ]
tries to hide what happens at the end
[ __ ] dies that's what happens
but uh that's that's what i'm sampson
but um
i i liked all uh i liked on the other
four before movies all right yeah i
think there's four of them
let's see uh casino royale casino royale
uh
squadron skype
yeah yeah
i liked them all
i did as well yeah i liked them all some
people were like dude man quantum masala
sucked no it didn't quantify i you know
what i did your favorite one i didn't
like it the first time i saw it but when
i saw it again i liked it better it's
still my least favorite of the of those
four but i liked it a lot better the
second i think i like it better than
skyfall because it just had so much
paranormal i think skyfall is still my
favorite it's still good but
there's a bunch of paranormal stuff that
happens in that you know the cat taxi
cab driver saying that his mother's
telling him about the the [ __ ] waters
going bad you know and so wow you know
what i mean and then there's there's a
lot of like uh fire
fire air water and oil metaphors you
know they're getting in the damn
you know what do you call it
uh
[ __ ] alchemy alchemy yeah that's
alchemical [ __ ] i knew what you're
thinking
about right
it's the most it's the most paranormal
of them all quantum solace i liked it
i liked it yeah yeah yeah well it way it
[ __ ]
it hinted that [ __ ] that the dead
could speak from the grave and tell you
the future you know that was another
thing that he could do and they were and
they told me the future yeah
and there was just like a um
just a bunch of death imagery and
[ __ ] afterlife in imagery i haven't
seen a long time and i can't really
there's only a couple things i can point
at making that [ __ ] drink the
oil at the end
because he was [ __ ] the motor oil
because he was trying to steal all the
water
it was just a pretty good idea i liked
it
fighting between the [ __ ] fire place
blowing up out the middle of the desert
pretty neat [ __ ] anyway um thank you
jeffy art glad you guys are back on the
air so are we hopefully the stream goes
well this is the first time i'm using a
mobile hotspot so we'll see uh hope the
move went well yeah after some
uh
some air
pulling it's pretty much settling down
yeah see badger thinks that he thought
[ __ ] quantum masalas was underrated
and better than skyfall i think it was
too man i thought that was better than
skyfall okay
i'm sorry wait i wasn't done okay great
uh by the way have you watched midnight
mass on netflix so good yeah that's it's
definitely on my list because that's
mike flanagan right and uh so yeah so so
many people have like recommended that
so i'm definitely gonna be watching that
because
i love all that [ __ ] yeah tila liked it
too
glad to see you've settled into your new
home yeah you know what we even got we
even brought like all the bar [ __ ] up
here yeah so we didn't have to go down
yeah he brought like a cooler of ice and
like all the [ __ ]
like a thing so he didn't have to go
downstairs and like make new drinks
because obviously like we're upstairs we
have upstairs now but you know that's
like super mike jumped in and said live
and let die was the most paranormal i
haven't seen that in a long time i'm
gonna see that again oh yeah i gotta go
back and see the old ones i haven't seen
a lot of the old ones in a long time i
mean i saw that but i can't i literally
cannot remember a single thing that
happened to that movie
yeah um i was
i was going to put the bar back there
behind spock
and i was thinking if i had a really
cool looking bar like one of those ones
where you can put the bottles on with
the light underneath it the show shines
up i want to see
how much those things are
but uh i don't think they're that
expensive if i remember correct maybe
they wanted tombot
oh yeah yeah like the like the smaller
one that kind of sits on yeah maybe get
something like that and put it in the
bag
yeah we'll put it on the screen
pimp this so when i go make a drink i
just go back there and make it right
there on screen
come back that's something that might be
a cool element of the [ __ ] i have to
have a bar in my office just like on mad
men if anybody wants to gift us with a
bar
if it shows up we'll throw it in we'll
throw it in
oh my god
john smith said i know this might make
me a pariah but my favorite bond was
always roger moore commence booing no
it's all good it's all good they all
brought their own [ __ ] at the time yeah
the roger moore ones they got kind of
ridiculous when he got as old as he got
you know what i mean i mean the dude's
damn near he's 60 something years old
and there's [ __ ] these 20 year old
[ __ ] supermodels [ __ ] coming on to
them it's like come on man
yeah it's like i'm not i'm not really
sure that that would be how that would
go down
and and at that point you know the roger
moore the roger moore bought he was a
superhero you know he didn't even get
dirty
yeah
well see that was part of his charm he
was like so unflappable you know what i
mean it's like he's not like us mere
mortals that like spill coffee on
ourselves on a daily basis
to like eat and have crumbs in their
beard and stuff like that
he's just like yeah that's i scuba dived
here and then i took off the scuba suit
and i had a perfect wrinkle-free tuxedo
underneath it [ __ ] there was one
james bond movie i saw in the theater
that i liked it when i was a i saw it
when i was a kid and i [ __ ] loved it
um i want to see it again i haven't seen
it in a long time but
they think it's called living daylights
and
living days yeah they didn't aha did the
song right
yeah thank you again zach oh my goodness
and it had the it had the um the dude
that played [ __ ] the uh
the
[ __ ] was that was that thunder yeah holy
[ __ ] it's been storming like all day
here you guys
had the dude that played uh
the [ __ ] prince baron from [ __ ]
flash gordon what's his name
he uh timothy dalton timothy dalton yeah
i think that was his only james bond
movie i think no he was in a couple
couple
well he was in living daylights and what
was the other one oh
i thought he was in two or three i liked
him as bond i remember i i got to go
back and see it santa and said he was in
two bonuses yeah i knew it wasn't a lot
okay it was like two or three i remember
it being hardcore that it was kind of
like the first realistic gritty bond
before before before daniel craig before
daniel craig when daniel craig came in i
thought he blew it out of the water i
liked it craig is super foxy yeah i
liked his bond
he's so like
like bro brumpled
[Laughter]
well he looks like he could fight
yeah well that's well but prior to him
being bond he was in like a lot of
british crime movies you know what i
mean which so i think that was like a
good pick yeah
and you know timothy dalton looked like
he could fight too
roger moore doesn't look like he could
fight i'm sorry
and then that other dude did he just
probably quip you to death yeah that
other dude uh that which is its own
talent who was that guy
who was who is the dude that [ __ ]
before uh what's his before here's
president pierce brosnan yeah pierce
brosnan said he didn't have a weight
behind him
he was all chest hair
that's all chest hair he could smother
you naked just like look like chuck
norris yeah that was chuck norris's
backup superpower he had his the last
one that last one that he did where he
was captured by the north koreans i kind
of liked it in a certain way but they
showed him [ __ ] coming out of that
prison he didn't have a shirt on and
everything i said dude that dude weighs
about 140 pounds and his chest hair
weighs his chest
it's like 80 pounds yeah and then they
got him doing all this acrobatic [ __ ]
beating up [ __ ] huge dudes you're
like come on man that's not how that
[ __ ] would go down he'd get this dude to
get crushed
sorry john smith said something very
funny daniel craig looks like a modern
steve mcqueen like he had whiskey and
steak for breakfast and a fist fight for
lunch yeah yeah
i think that's why i i really really
like like the daniel craig bond movies
like i watched the ones before and i was
you know i was kind of into him and i
was kind of into him a lot in the 80s
because obviously when duran duran did
view to a kill and stuff because i was
super into duran duran in 85 but
i think i didn't really appreciate them
as much until i saw the daniel craig
ones because daniel craig is just such a
good bond but like i said everybody has
their own take on the character and i
would never say oh that guy was a shitty
bond they all had their own like charms
to them so i'm not gonna [ __ ] on anybody
that likes any particular one because
that's not that's not how i do they're
telling me not to hate i'm mostly just
thinking of the [ __ ] in that last pierce
brosnan movie
uh that was the one that kind of stood
out as being not too good
it was um
now i'm getting now again madonna did
the song did the theme song for it oh
[ __ ] it's about not uh he gets captured
by the north koreans
um
it looked really good some of the cg on
it [ __ ] sucked
well when did it come out 90s
was it 90s or early 2000s
because a lot of the cgi back then
sucked in all the movies even like even
the really expensive movies like had
shitty cgi yeah
the one with halle berry sucked said
santa
i don't even know if i saw that one
all right so we ready to get into this
case well i had a couple of uh shout
outs okay give the show what i wanted to
do
uh so uh first of all i wanted to thank
our patron mary ellen who's been a
patron for a long time uh she actually
increased her patreon support this week
so thank you very much mary ellen also
got a couple of paypal donations one of
them is for esther and she is not here
tonight because unfortunately she was
taken to the emergency room and they're
not letting her out until tomorrow uh
i'm not really sure
what's the matter i hope it's okay we
wish her the best obviously but thank
you esther hopefully you're gonna watch
this later on and uh also ilsa sent me a
paypal donation earlier today as a late
birthday present so thank you very much
ilsa you are awesome
uh all you guys are awesome you know how
it is so um do you what uh uh yes derma
it was die another day there you go that
was what i was thinking of i get them
all mixed up yeah madonna did a good
theme song for it i liked it i can't
even remember what is this what did the
theme song sound like sing it uh
i can't
i can't it's it's uh
i just remember liking it showed
scorpions fighting each other
cgi scorpion's fine it was pretty good
cgi scorpions yeah well they looked kind
of cgi they were kind of clear looking
um it was
the movie was funny because i have i
have all of his movies on blu-ray
yeah i've seen he's got like the whole
daniel craig i got all no it also got
all the piercing ones oh that's right i
forgot you bought this yeah
but diet another day
man it kind of jumped a shark but it was
a mixed bag parts it had elements in it
that i really liked but there was other
stuff that comes yeah that's what i mean
it's like all of them all of them have
something that's worth watching in there
but then some of them have like some
cheesy [ __ ] in there too and
i don't know i i think the the bond
movies that came out probably in the 90s
and early 2000s
suffered a lot from the same stuff that
i don't like in other movies that came
out in the 90s and early 2000s like
shitty looking cgi everything looks like
a video game cut scene
and just other kind of [ __ ] that i don't
know other other filmmaking [ __ ] that
was going on back then that i wasn't a
fan of yeah so you know what i did like
about the brosnan about the brosnan bond
is that that
he gets introduced to the walther p99
which is a fantastic [ __ ] pistol now
it's called the ppq
but the p99 had had a better [ __ ]
trigger on it
if you guys ever had one i've had many
of them i've had all those
i can i like walters they're pretty good
but you know the rest of the world
caught up with walter there was a time
in the [ __ ]
90s in the 80s where [ __ ] walter was
[ __ ] real special in terms of [ __ ]
craftsmanship and just the feel of the
stuff you know same way back in the 60s
too you know they're good you know the
pp and the
ppk but everybody else [ __ ] is coming
out with some nice [ __ ] even smith
is coming out with [ __ ] nice that m p
and 360 that [ __ ] was that 365 i
don't think smith did that maybe he did
or was that sick i get them confused
sometimes some of these new ones
but even the glocks are [ __ ]
fantastic nowadays
mike barrett says die another day is the
worst
[Laughter]
oh and kyle says chris cornell's theme
for casino royale was awesome yes i
agree that was an awesome [ __ ] song
and i love that whole title sequence
yeah that titles i could just watch that
title sequence on a loop like all day
long with that song and everything are
you going to die
i mean i liked all the songs from the
craig like all the theme songs oh my
name yeah [ __ ] was bad i like the alicia
keys one though from f i did as well
that was really good from quantum
masalas yeah the one from uh spectre was
a little downbeat i didn't like that one
as much oh it's kind of gross on you but
yeah i didn't mind that yeah what was
that guy's name it's just kind of a
ballad
it's john legend didn't it yeah
didn't it marvel it didn't it did i pull
that out of my ass i can't
that casino royale one man that one [ __ ]
that's a great song that one really gets
you you're like yeah that's right that's
a great song it's just it's like it
really like uh that's like the essence
of bond movies yeah and then the the
[ __ ] like the the the intro credits
the dude's [ __ ] knife fighting and
the [ __ ]
yeah the [ __ ] diamonds hearts and
spades flying sam smith yeah that's
right dude's shooting just silhouettes
to do the shooting it looks like a motif
on the back of a [ __ ] playing card
and instead of brass cases flying out i
think it's [ __ ] what is it
it's like yeah it's like card suits card
suits flying out they're thinking yeah
that was bad i mean night fights shout
out to all the like uh visual designers
that do those titles i'm a big fan of
like title sequences because like i said
i'm a graphic designer i've been graphic
designer for like 25 years so anytime
you can make like a movie title sequence
that looks like super awesome that just
makes me want to watch it over and over
again
big props i'm i'm really i noticed that
kind of [ __ ]
you go back and watch all the craig
bombs bond movies all that [ __ ] that
they talked about those movies came true
about google
spectre and all that [ __ ] you know
exactly they're talking about
[ __ ] they're even hinting at the
[ __ ] agenda 21.
okay that's all i'm gonna say about it
there's the undertone they knew exactly
what they were talking about i can't
believe they got away with it
the world is run by bond villains
[ __ ] very rich oligarchs that [ __ ]
try to [ __ ] up nations that's that's
exactly what that [ __ ] series is
about there's a lot of truth in it
thank you again zach
seeing skye fall and carrie from 1976 at
the same time
inspired me to pursue filmmaking for a
career back in 2012. see there you go
[Laughter]
yeah let's see okay where
do
do
hugo says i like the film that nobody
likes on her majesty's secret service
i've never seen that was that the only
one with george lazenby yeah i think
that's the one that dude he was the one
like the brand then he was like man [ __ ]
this i don't want to make a career out
of this which you know can't blame the
guy but whatever
santa said i haven't seen any daniel
craig bonds
i actually i have actually really liked
the daniel cruz i was like i said i was
kind of a lukewarm on the bond series
before that like i saw most of them over
the years but i didn't really care about
them but i don't know the daniel craig
ones i really like for whatever reason
i'm not really sure what that says about
me well they're fun
and they're um
kind of gritty
and a little bit more realistic yeah
because i do kind of feel like maybe the
things that turned me off about the
bonds from the earlier era where they
were kind of cheesy a little bit cheesy
and like i didn't really like like a lot
of humor in there they were superhero
movies basically yeah and i was just
kind of like come on man
you like take it off your scuba suit
there's like a tuxedo under there it's
like that's funny but you know
yeah and then you end up in a casino and
you're [ __ ] nobody
you climb through a sewer in a wetsuit
and come up in a [ __ ] and nobody's
like and then you smell them
and you got a [ __ ] tuxedo on and
nobody notices that you know you stink
[Laughter]
yeah it's like you know the the laws of
the physical universe like still do
apply to you right
matter of fact but yeah
uh yeah so i did the shout outs right
yeah yeah
yeah
yeah right yeah you gonna you gonna
survive i'll make it we got up so early
this morning yes i got after like six
he's been going back to the old house
like i said to
work on this [ __ ] yeah it's almost done
yeah it's almost done i'm like i got the
weekend off though
okay that's good yeah we're gonna go
we're gonna go to the club tomorrow
we're gonna go to tampa and see some
bands we're gonna go to absolution fest
it'll be fun yeah
all right so you want to talk about
[ __ ] elliot roger yeah let's go ahead
and get into it i mean
what i was gonna do because i put all
the in-cell [ __ ] first and i was like
why did i do that it's like maybe we
should just like talk about
elliot roger first and then we'll kind
of like expand out and talk about
the incel community and the man-o-sphere
as they call it the manosphere which is
the mgtow guys
men going their own way your puas your
pickup artists
all that kind of crap uh which has been
going on for a long time but i think it
really like kind of
came to light i think it kind of came to
mainstream attention with the elliot
roger thing because he had been
posting in a lot of those forums
particularly like pua hate
um that subreddit
that was kind of one that he was on all
the time you know what i'm saying and so
i think that's been banned but there's
other ones that are like that
and uh it's kind of alarming if you go
to them
how
there's a certain segment not all of
them obviously but there's a certain
segment of the intel community
that
um kind of worship elliot roger
um
[Music]
and they uh they make like all kind of
memes about him like where they kind of
make him look like a saint
and uh you know if some of them if if
some of the people on the forums like
express suicidal thoughts
they're like oh well take some women out
with you
damn just like elliot roger did i'm just
like that's charming no wonder you can't
get laid i'm just i mean like
not to be mean it's like i get okay
here's the thing i'm really really
i really struggle with this because i
look i understand i don't i'm not into
like bullying people i'm not into like
making fun of people's pain i understand
that these dudes are lonely and they
feel like nobody loves them and i get
that and that's not cool to like bully
people because of that
but i feel like the
let's put it this way the route that
they have chosen to take
to address
quote unquote these
issues
is not helping and in fact making things
worse they're compounding
the problem
and they don't either they don't seem to
see it or
honestly i think most of them are just
using
this
in-cell [ __ ] like this in-cell identity
as an excuse
not to go out and try to meet women
because they're afraid they're afraid
they're going to get rejected which they
will everybody gets rejected even good
looking people get rejected all the time
and it's just kind of like i just feel
like they're using an excuse like to not
do that you know what i'm saying
maybe
i don't know i i feel like there's
there's an element of that going on
what it what what are your thoughts on
it what are my thoughts on it what are
your thoughts on it
go ahead we're on topic the data
the data suggests and i think probably
proves
that a 100 of the women
find
about 80 percent of the men unacceptable
so there's already a problem there okay
this is called the what is that called
the pareto principle or whatever it's
called which is very big in in cell
circles they talk about that all the
time i'm not sure is this true it is
true no it is true and there's a lot of
there's a lot of um there's a lot of
data to back it up
uh uh [ __ ] computer data a lot of
stuff that can back it up in the animal
kingdom
it's the same in other species the
females are chasing mostly the top 20
percent of the of the available males
now
that top 20 percent is a certain
demographic
age demographic and income demographic
or a certain
you know charisma demographic women do
not chase urine stained bums
they don't well nobody i mean men don't
chase urine stains bum they don't either
no they don't
and they don't chase 80 or 90 year old
women
okay
so it's kind of like the same thing the
dating thing and the mating and dating
thing is a selective
process it would not be mating if it was
not selective
you know what i mean
human beings and all other animals are
kind of selected selectively bred
there's a certain time in which you're
supposed to mate there's competitions
for that
only that top 20 percent
is supposedly
acceptable now doesn't mean that
the ones that are unacceptable don't
mate they do sometimes they even [ __ ]
well most children most people
do
exactly most people have at least one
relationship in their life right
the thing is with when you're talking
about these particular guys who are on
these forums
doing all this complaining about their
situation
they tend to be
guys that for for some reason or another
they're they're not gonna be
popular
you know with females
so then they're going to talk [ __ ] about
it but they're just a statistic more
than anything else i mean they're a
human being
but they're also a statistic you know
what i mean i'm kind of into my drinks
but
[Laughter]
just because they're not getting laid
doesn't mean those other guys aren't
getting laid
and looks don't have a lot you know like
i said books are part of it most people
get laid at some point most people right
you know what i mean um
yeah but with these dudes there's
there's also behavioral problems there's
like well yeah lack of skill
there's a lack of charisma uh which some
of this is genetic too so some of them
can't be helped
i don't know well yeah there's probably
a certain percentage but i honestly i
think most of them
if they have the wherewithal and the
intelligence and stuff like that to post
online i kind of feel like the problem
with a lot of them not all of them
um some of them might have some
undiagnosed mental issues okay so that's
fine
but i think a lot of them too they sort
of like
it seems like they want to
i don't know i think a lot of it is just
that they you know for whatever reason
they get into this feedback loop where
you know they think they're
ugly or unacceptable or something like
that and they go online and like to
commiserate with others of the similar
kind of thing and then they end up going
down this whole rabbit hole
where
they blame everybody else for them not
getting their own [ __ ] together
you know what i mean and then it just
gets to a point where well it's hopeless
i can't but a lot of these guys if they
just like
cleaned themselves up and like kind of
looked inward and kind of like changed
themselves a little bit like worked on
themselves a little bit like weren't so
weird and creepy and [ __ ] like that
they'd probably do all right i think a
thing about it too is that and i think
tila brought this up a little bit uh or
somebody brought this up earlier is that
the problem with a lot of these dudes
too is that if there's a double standard
they're always they're always like these
really dumpy you know dudes that live in
their mom's basement they want to go out
with a tag yeah they want to go out with
super they're mad because supermodels
don't pay attention to them but it's
like so i never understood yeah and it's
like but if they were like you know if
they went to like a gaming form or if
they went to like a comic store or
something like that or something that
they were interested in and met a girl
there who maybe wasn't like a supermodel
but had the same interests as them maybe
they would you know
find something in common maybe they
would hook up they maybe they'd start
dating but they don't want to do that
they only want
these gorgeous like shallow women they
degrade them as stacy's that's what they
call them but they won't you know even
if a girl did show them interest if the
girl was like a little bit overweight or
she wasn't pretty or she had acne or
something like that the guys wouldn't
pay any attention to her
yeah
but they but then they get on women for
being shallow and evil and cruel and
[ __ ] like that but they're the same
they're the same i think it's genetic
factors
okay
a lot of these guys who are
who behave the way you're talking about
i think that the the way you're talking
about
if you were okay okay
let's say elliot rogers you look at him
and physically you would think he would
be acceptable you would think that that
guy
could it could get a date all right he's
not he's not ugly he's just weird
okay
and
he wasn't successful because of his
weirdness
i think what caused that weirdness was
some something genetic
um
yeah he seemed to have issues when heat
from when he was a kid
we inherit a lot of our disposition and
we inherit
some of our [ __ ]
thinking and [ __ ] from our parents
and then there's also
mutations going on so some of these guys
are mutants you know in a certain way
a dude who
looks like [ __ ] ignores himself
all right
has no ambition
gets really [ __ ] overweight but then
expects a 10 or to go out with an eight
or a nine
there's gonna be some problem somewhere
in his brain because he lacks the
ability
to [ __ ] judge himself and to
understand
the situation that he's that he doesn't
have anything to offer he's got nothing
right exactly so when i say genetic
factors that's what i'm talking about
genes are you know
the mind is also an expression of genes
not just the body the body is an
expression of your genetic makeup so is
your mind
it's it's it's holistic
so
there's always going to be a certain
amount of people in the world that are
going to fall into this misfit category
you know they're not going to make it
well the thing about her is not friendly
the thing about it is that even
people that are misfits the majority of
them
if they were willing to
hang out with other misfits
then they would probably be all right
but they don't want to do that but that
does happen they don't want to do that a
lot of
we're talking
usually that does happen misfits hang
out with other misfits and go out with
them that's what the norm
we're not talking about them we're
talking about these guys which are not
the norm
it's genetic i'm telling you
there's something about their mind to
where they cannot self-analyze
their situational awareness isn't good
the weird thing about elliot roger in
particular was that it's not that weird
because i understand
why it happens
he was a very strange
mixture
of
self-loathing
and
breathtaking
arrogance yeah
he thought that
it was almost kind of like he thought he
was [ __ ] but then he over compensated by
thinking he was superior to everyone
else
and so like when he talked like if you
watch his videos and stuff and you can
see them all over the place like all
over youtube and you know people other
people opposed to them
and he just has this really smug
condescending
superior attitude he's so much better
than everyone else
um
and
it's really weird about him too because
he has this very deluded
um
idea of
how his life went he
thought and he wrote like a [ __ ]
manifesto anybody that writes a
manifesto you watch out for that
[ __ ]
that's a red flag right right [ __ ]
manifesto
and it was like a hundred and seven
thousand words it's like long it was
like as long as a novel i'm like dude no
one cares that much about you
so yeah so i mean i'm sure some people
you know a good author [ __ ] hard
nobody wants to read them hardly that's
what i mean it's like come on nobody
wants to read your [ __ ] delusional
ramblings knock it off but the thing
that really struck me about it was that
he had this very strange
idea that i'm okay i'm gonna give the
world i'm gonna give women of the world
one more chance
to
you know recognize how awesome i am
but he would do that by like basically
just existing like he didn't yeah that's
something yeah he he wouldn't like go
out and try to meet people
he wouldn't he didn't do anything he
just expected everybody hey i'm
marginally good-looking and intelligent
and i have a nice car
so [ __ ] should just fall in my lap and
when it didn't he got mad
and i'm like he's not even attempting to
to make friends or anything like that
nothing and it's like people that knew
him like in school and stuff like that
were like we didn't even know like he
wouldn't even talk yeah he didn't do
anything he didn't ask anybody out he
didn't do anything like that tila bring
brings up a good point she said that
these guys remind remind her of the dude
from the hand
it was the movie i recommended her she
liked michael caine was a movie called
the hand
they they watch it but they can't it
they can't even self evaluate they can't
even evaluate themselves there's no
insight into what they're doing
they can't see how they relate to the
world everything is me me me me
yeah these guys are like that it's this
it's narcissism and it's just it's i
mean
and an ugly [ __ ] can be
narcissistic and matter of fact a
narcissist will tend to be [ __ ]
[ __ ] up and ugly because he loves
himself so much that he doesn't even try
because he doesn't think he has he
doesn't think he has to he's like a
[ __ ] weinstein [ __ ] weinstein
[ __ ] when you take a bath and
then he'd go rape some beautiful actress
and [ __ ] because he didn't have to he
knew he was disgusting jabba the hutt
basically
but
yeah that's what you're talking about
with this and i think that
some of these mental
predispositions are genetic
you can't help them
i've known people like that you can't
talk to them and get them to change
their ways that's what they are
well i kind of feel like and this is
gonna sound weird but you know this is
we do a lot of true crime [ __ ] and i saw
this mentioned by somebody else like on
a documentary about elliot roger too
it's just like the narcissism that he
displays he's like that's very common in
killers and serial killers and people
that you know are mass killers like he
was
um is just this
like you said they seem to have an
inability to look inward yeah and be
like maybe am i reading this wrong am i
because they don't have
the humility i guess
or the objectivity to see themselves
from outside and be like how is my
behavior coming across to other people
you know is there something that i could
do am i something is there something
that i'm projecting
that that are making people react to me
this way they don't really seem to be
able to these dudes
even though they're [ __ ] losers in
somebody's basement wearing [ __ ] up
[ __ ] up shorts from the 70s and
[ __ ] tube socks with [ __ ] the
three stripes and the [ __ ] wearing
[ __ ] up [ __ ]
even though they look like that
they are narcissists they [ __ ] love
themselves so much that they don't think
nature and rules apply to them
yeah say
mating is the ultimate in the animal
nature in in in the real world
some bird some male bird is trying to
get pretty as a [ __ ] doing his
dads
and trying to attract the females
i love watching
he's got tinsel that he stole from the
christmas tree and bottle caps and [ __ ]
he's trying to eat as many [ __ ]
little guppies as he can to get fat
they're competing
mating is a com competition
even a big ass [ __ ] lion okay
he can't just mate it's not free
he's got to chase off the other male
lions to get into the female pride and
take over
and to do that is risky they get bit
they get infected and they die
and it's like that with all animals and
human beings are [ __ ] animals and
that's not a bad thing that's a good
thing
we apply we have to apply
to those exact same rules you gotta do
[ __ ]
males have to do things they just do
you have to achieve status
women don't like low status men they
just don't
a high status man
has character and charisma because he's
going out doing things he's taking
losses he's getting gains
uh he you know he can he he's a man for
all seasons
he can go out and have adventure but
then he can kind of settle down with a
woman
it's
he has something to offer
yeah and not going inward he that dude
didn't go inward he went outward yeah
he's dealing with the environment you
have to be competent
that's what the women are looking for
well that's what i mean i feel like and
particularly in the incel community i
feel like they have
they have kind of a misunderstanding
that it's like oh all women want is
money
that's not me that's not that's not the
case maybe in a small percentage of gold
diggers but
women want a man who like i said has
something to offer just like a man wants
a you know what wants a woman that has
something to tell you guys something
when i live you don't have to be rich
you don't have to be you just have to
have something jenny is my witness
remember when we were driving but we
went by sylvan and we went by that big
old mansion outside by that that barn
and i said i know the dude who married
that that woman remember
yeah okay
back in brazil i used to write it at
hipikopalista which is the sao paulo
hippica which is the english writing
equestrian
center in in sao paulo brazil
there was a kid there he was my age a
couple years younger
who was a groom
from the favela he was from [ __ ]
nothing
but he loved horses
he moved to the united states and
learned enough as a groom the groom just
cleans horses and walks horses around
puts them in stables muck stalls okay
but he learned enough to where he got
here in florida to talk his way into
being a trainer he married a woman who a
girl a woman who
she's well
i would call her a girl
because that happened when she was in
her 30s you know um so but now she's
she's a woman um he married her
and she came from an amazingly wealthy
family
and he now lives in a mansion and runs
one of the best barns in the little area
that i was at and that's got to be a
four or five million dollar facility
he didn't have a pot to piss in
but he was brazilian but he had
something else good looking he had
ambition and he could talk
he was willing to work for it yeah
um you know he had a good personality
and and he for all you know the
[ __ ] was swinging
but he was popular with women we don't
know
citation needed
in the horse industry you know a lot of
the trainers that rise to the top are
charismatic trainers [ __ ] females
want a charismatic male trainer yeah i
mean nobody wants to hang out with
somebody that's like a bummer right and
nobody wants to hang out with somebody
that's complaining all the time about
how the world shits on them and they're
not that and usually the trainers are
not training at the advanced level it's
the very basic level just [ __ ] you
know walk trot post [ __ ] canter you
know [ __ ] you know basic equitation
some very basic jump jumping [ __ ]
techniques and [ __ ]
how to take care of your attack
and he was just not a euphemism yeah
very very basic knowledge he was able to
basically be a multi-multi-millionaire
through a woman
okay no shame in that
no shame in that at all well that's the
way it's supposed to work really i mean
one thing that really alarmed me like i
said i watched a [ __ ] ton of like in
cell division and i saw the bar and
there's a beautiful bar yeah yeah i
watched a ton of like in cell
documentaries i even watched this one i
saw this uh listen this one podcast was
really interesting um i think it's
called other people's lives and they had
a guy on there who had been in the in
cell community then he got out and he
was kind of talking about his mindset
like through all that time and the
hilarious well hilarious and [ __ ] up
and horrifying at the same time
was that one of the things that led him
to abandon the incel movement was his
realization
that women are also people
and i was like
wow it really took you that i'm like you
know i'm sorry dude i'm glad that you
got out of that [ __ ] but seriously it
took you that long to realize that women
are a person just like you also with
problems also with issues
um
that are no different than you are
they're not all we're not all of a
[ __ ] hive mind or something like that
so i kind of the one of the thing that
disturbs me the most i think about the
insult community is that this weird
they almost see women as like this
monolithic
uh like i said like a hive mind they
don't see them as human beings there's
also something i think that was which is
very disturbing something the comments
mentioned this there was also
um i think
a uh
kind of like this thing that was going
on
in this in sale community if you want to
call it the insale community um well
yeah it's a community it's mostly online
but yeah it's still a community they
also seem to have kind of a
the will to be outsiders because that
also narcissism it makes them special
yeah well that's what i was saying
before it's like i have to be accepted
yeah because they i'm the elephant man
they they hate me yeah [ __ ] no they
just don't notice you dude yeah it's
like you guys you we saw the elephant
man he looked like that and he was still
like a charming lovely
person normal dude you don't have to be
well like he was dying anyway because he
had a lot of health issues so if you do
you look as bad as the elephant man no
you don't you're right you don't have to
be an [ __ ]
the fact of you being an [ __ ] is way
more of a factor in you not getting laid
then you just like looking like a slob
yeah and i can tell you that for a
[ __ ] fact right now
um i honestly an elliot roger like i
said he doesn't have the excuse of like
look because he didn't he looked like a
normal dude he had a nice clothes he had
a nice car you know he came from a
moderately wealthy family
so he didn't have a lot of the excuses
that a lot of these other dudes have
it's like oh i don't have any money or
i'm fat or whatever and women don't like
me
um but
he the thing about him was that he
projected such an air of arrogance
and
just being a [ __ ] weirdo that
people avoided not just women everybody
avoided him because
of the way that he came across it was
his personality was
unappealing
i've run into guys like that before but
they weren't the kind of like uh they
weren't centered on you know this pretty
boy he's kind of had the pretty boy act
and worried about women i've known guys
that were just like that but were not
worried more about like mathematics
or worried about you know what i mean
worried about [ __ ] science
i think yeah
like i hadn't pegged some kind of
asperger's they seem like asperger's
well elliot roger was was diagnosed as
being on the autism spectrum as well but
the thing about it is that another thing
that i think is a problem
is that i think
western culture in general puts too much
emphasis on
sex and losing your virginity
as being like well you can't be a man
until you've banged x amount of women or
until like if you're still a virgin in
your 20s that means you're lame or
whatever so i think that there's too
much pressure
um
so i so i feel like somebody like elliot
roger because it seemed like he could
have like a zillion other interests
and that could just be a minor thing oh
you know i don't have a girlfriend
that's kind of a bummer but it's just
like he focused his whole entire
attention
on that
on i don't have a girlfriend or girls
don't like me
and that seemed like he based his whole
entire identity around that [ __ ] like he
didn't really have anything else going
on and i think that's another problem i
think that he just really
it was
yeah that was like he was like too hyper
focused on
you know getting it's like look losing
your virginity and stuff like that yeah
it's a rate of passage and all this
stuff but it's not that big of a deal
and i feel like they build it up in
their minds
to where it's going to be this big i'm
passing the veil into adult now i'm a
man and this and that the other and i
feel like putting too much importance on
it like that is just really
that's also really not good because
you're just like building up something
that really in the grand scheme of
things is not really all that important
you know what i'm saying
so i feel like that's kind of another
factor as well
um prepper pov it says wouldn't you kind
of think that elliot was possibly gay by
how he acted i don't know he never came
across he never read as gay to me he
just kind of he came across as a
feminist he came well he always just
read to me as is creepy not so much
creepy but just like really really
arrogant he came he always came across
as like really arrogant and smug which i
hate to me he was like an effeminate
robot
yeah he really didn't like he really
didn't seem to have much self-insight
did he some some [ __ ] that wrote 170
107 000 words it was like it was a
manifesto he was ai didn't really seem
to have a lot of insight into his own
i don't know like he
it just i don't know i it i just feel
like like i said i'm not i don't
i don't want to like bully people that
are lonely or they get bullied or you
know that get picked on because that
sucks okay like it happened to me too
and it's like it's not fun so i don't
want to like [ __ ] on people that that
happened to but i don't think that the
solution
is to turn into this
whatever the [ __ ] he turned into where
he just thought he was better than
everyone else and he just deserved
everything
i mean some of the [ __ ] that he said
like on his videos and in his manifesto
for christ's sake
he literally thought all he had to do
was exist
and hot women should just fall into his
lap and because they didn't he was going
to punish the [ __ ] world for that he
really thought i mean that is the
definition of entitlement
he even used that word
that he felt he was entitled to
women's attention yeah women didn't know
he existed he was just we're just going
about our [ __ ] lives man
you're trying to you're trying to use
reason to figure out somebody who you
can't figure out that way that that is
some kind of a [ __ ] organic problem
there's some kind of genetic defect in
the brain
you know what i mean
it's kind of like like you know the same
similar type of defect it might happen
in a serial killer he doesn't have any
[ __ ] insight
no self announcement well yeah it's it's
really not that different i mean
the psychology between the lizard yeah
the psychology between uh you know
serial killers and spree killers which
is what elliot roger was are slightly
different but they have a lot of
similarities and like you said you know
lack of insight is one of them
he felt very robotic to me
he did kind of like a robot yeah and uh
i was watching a documentary about him
earlier and they had um a guy who was
like a psychiatrist and he was like
analyzing like a lot of the stuff and
and he said the thing that strikes me
the most about him like after his
arrogance is his detachment yeah uh the
way he talks he just seems very detached
like when he's talking about you know in
these videos about
all the [ __ ] that he's gonna do
he just yeah he just seems very very
detached so like i said very similar
psychology to uh serial killers so
as i said we'll kind of we'll talk about
elliot rogers the the uh
it's it's isla vista right isla or
eisler is i saw i heard it pronounced
earlier but it's just like i can't
remember how they pronounced it
so i don't i don't even know what i'm
gonna do but i'm gonna talk about those
first which happened in 2014 and then
we'll kind of like expand out and talk
about because
uh unfortunately this [ __ ]
wasn't the first one to do this or he
well he wasn't the first one but then
like after he did it and then brought
the whole thing into the mainstream
there were a bunch of i don't know if
i'd call them copycats but there were a
bunch of other incel
killers like a bunch of other
mass murderers that were inspired by him
inspired by the incel movement so you
know that's fun uh yeah so we'll get
into talking about that
yeah i love this stuff that's the thing
i was like i kept looking at it and i
was like
man i want to pronounce that a certain
way and so i watched like i watched a
couple documentaries i'm like i got to
make sure i got that pronunciation right
and then when i went to say it like i
could remember i said
oh
uh
yeah uh john smith says am i the only
one who thinks the rise of spree killers
is linked to the rise in forensic
science it's just too hard to be a
serial killer these days science will
catch your ass quickly it could be it
could very well be that because i do
feel like serial killing has been on the
decline
uh since the 90s thank you if you need
more ice i'll put more ice in it thanks
and like you said that might be because
of forensic technology but yeah it's um
it does really seem like their
psychologies are so similar that maybe
people that would have been a serial
killer before they're just like [ __ ] it
i'm just gonna go one big blaze of glory
like [ __ ] ellie
i hate to call it that but
that's what elliot roger did i mean
uh the [ __ ] this dude says i just i know
he's dead but
happily but
watching the videos of him again like
doing the research for this show i was
just like man i just want to like dig
you up from the grave so i can slap you
all over all over again you [ __ ]
douchebag yeah he's not in his right
mind i know i know that and and the sad
thing about it is that i know we can
talk about like how the system failed
him and stuff like that but it it really
does seem like his parents did try to
help him um you know the authorities did
try to help him uh his parents even saw
the videos that he posted and reported
it to the police and said hey our son
might be thinking about doing some
[ __ ] up [ __ ]
and i don't know if the police
necessarily took it all that seriously
so it does seem like
because i mean he kind of had the
privilege of having you know um
fairly i don't think they were wealthy
but i think they were you know they you
know they had money like his parents
they were in the movie business
and um
so it's not like
you know he it's not like he was some
poor kid who didn't have any resources
at his disposal he did have his parents
did like were concerned and they did
take him to therapists and stuff like
that problem was they you know they
prescribed medication for him except he
wouldn't take it because he'd done his
own research and he's like oh i don't
need that so he would pretend that he
took it i guess and then he didn't take
it um so obviously it can't help you if
you don't take it so i don't know if uh
if he would have taken it maybe he
wouldn't have
gone down this road but just the [ __ ]
then the [ __ ] [ __ ] that he says is
just
ugh man it was just like watching it all
over again i was like jesus [ __ ]
christ and then like having to go down
the rabbit hole
of all the incel kind of [ __ ] it's just
like reading it it just depresses me so
much these people just depress me so
much i don't know what their [ __ ]
problem is
but yeah so
2014.
uh so elliot roger
is 22 years old uh when this happened
let's kind of talk about his
background though now the interesting
thing about him
is that he was actually born in london
uh so he was english-born because his
dad is british i believe now his dad uh
is in the movie business um he actually
worked on i think he was second unit
director in one of the hunger games
movies so
elliot roger was kind of like in
kind of bit like movie circles like he
went to film premieres and all that kind
of [ __ ] so yeah
you